Leonardo da Vinci famously said
to achieve a complete mind study the art
of science study the science of art
learn how to see realize that everything
connects to everything else maybe I'm
seeing the world as I am rather than as
it is and it's all related to frequency
and the entire universe is based on
frequency
and then you start thinking about well
wait a minute geometry and music are
related too and maybe music is just the
geometry that we experience with our
ears and maybe geometry is just the
music that we experience with our eyes
and when I kind of heard that for the
first time I started really recognizing
I think what he really meant by that is
this beautiful geometric
scope of experience